the NBA is looking to drop the term
owner for team owners because the term
owner is now apparently racist we will
examine the ramifications of this new
change from owning small businesses to
owning the libs
then a grinder hookup goes horribly
wrong when a kinky fantasy turns into
assault and robbery
that's the sexual revolution for you the
Pope has rewritten the Lord's Prayer and
we look back on 100 years of female
suffrage
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Knowles show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so much suffrage I hope we have time to
get to it at the end of the show because
everyone argues over susan b anthony zeg
ascesis and b anthony more than any
other woman gave women the right to vote
she was the leading suffrage yet and
there's a major debate on the right and
the left on who gets to own susan b
anthony and i will give you the true
answer to that but first losing your
hair is terrible did you know that two
out of three guys will experience hair
loss by the time they are thirty-five
and this is something that really
terrifies me because I'm not a huge
hulking adonis of a man my poufy hair is
is one of my real perks you know to keep
sweet little ELISA interested in me this
brings us to keeps the easiest and most
affordable way to keep the hair that you
have the FDA approved products used to
cost so much money but now thanks to
keeps they're finally inexpensive and
easy to obtain for five minutes now and
starting in just ten bucks per month you
will never have to worry about hair loss
again getting started is super easy
signing up takes less than five minutes
I know guys just want to put off
everything and procrastinate not do it
don't lose your hair you can stop the
process of hair loss but you got to act
now answer a few simple questions snap
some photos to complete your online
doctor consultation a licensed physician
will review your information online and
recommend the right treatment for you
then it is shipped right to your door
every three months keeps offers generic
versions of the only two fda-approved
hair loss products out there you may
have tried them before but never for
this price ten bucks to 35 bucks a month
plus now you can get your first month
for each one hell of a deal for keeping
your hair guys this is all about peace
of mind
I have great peace of mind because I
have keeps so I know that my hair is not
gonna just all fall out one day and then
I'm gonna lose my show and lose my wife
and have a terrible life if you suffer
from hair loss the last thing you need
is to wait to see a doctor with keeps
there's finally a way to get the help
that you need when you need it for a
limited time receive your first month of
treatment for free go to keeps calm /
anoles Kenna wles that is to receive
your first month of treatment for free
go to keeps calm / Knolls KO wles
we will get to women's suffrage later
right now we need to talk about
whole other class of victim group a
major change happening in the NBA a
number of NBA teams are trying to drop
the word owner from the phrase team
owner you know if you own an NBA team
you're an owner of an NBA team right but
apparently no that's wrong that's racist
you're not allowed to be that anymore so
the Philadelphia 76ers rebranded their
owners as managing partners why are they
doing this because they say owner is
racist because slave owners own slaves
so therefore the word owner is ruined
forever you can't use the word owner so
they're managing partners that the
trouble is managing partner doesn't mean
the same thing as owner businesses have
managing partners who are not owners and
owners who are not managing partners the
LA Clippers are calling their owners the
Chairman so the majority stake holder in
in the LA Clippers knows chairman the
reason that this is happening one of the
big causes of this is draymond Green of
the Golden State Warriors told to the
HBO Sports Show the shop that he found
the term racially insensitive and it's
gotta go here's the interview when your
product is purely the labor of people
then owner sounds like something that is
of a futile nature you shouldn't say so
if that voice sounded familiar by the
way from the interviewer that was Jon
Stewart he has come out of his cabin in
the woods from Daily Show retirement and
he's doing this interview and he he
brings up the question he says the term
owner is racist
so they bat around a few different ideas
they say how about majority shareholder
okay I mean a majority shareholder and a
slave plantation is also pretty bad too
right is that is that term unacceptable
that it's all about the term owner and
and Jon Stewart's point is if a business
is only about someone else's labor you
shouldn't be an owner because then it's
like you own that person so can a
restaurant have an owner a restaurant is
primarily about other people's labor
it's about the waiters and the Busboys
and the kitchen runners and the cooks
and
the chef and the manager and the hostess
and the cleaning crew
so our restaurants allowed to have
owners an hour no that's not anymore now
you might say well a restaurant provides
a physical product too they provide food
so therefore it's not only about
somebody else's labor and basketball you
know basketball is just about the labor
of the basketball players also that
isn't true
so basketball is primarily about
entertainment it's primarily about what
the basketball players are doing but
there are a ton of tangibles that go
along with it you buy the Jersey you buy
the sneakers you buy the hotdogs at the
stadium you buy the beers you buy the
trading cards there a lot of very
physical objects that go along with it
that are at least in part owned by the
owners of these teams even if it were
true though let's say that basketball
were only about the physical labor of
others and so you've got these team
owners and they don't just own these
basketball players what about Hollywood
what about any other sort of
entertainment field basketball is
primarily about entertainment you sit
down and you watch a basketball game to
be entertained TV shows are also about
entertainment movies are also about
entertainment concerts are also a bad
entertainment is it racist to call movie
studio owners owners is a racist to call
record label owners owners no obviously
not there are two issues that are at
play here
there's one historical ignorance and two
creeping socialism the historical
ignorant is just over what the term
owner means obviously it's true slave
owners were referred to as owners people
who owned anything else for all of the
history of mankind are also referred to
as owners it's not an explicitly or or
even primarily or even frequently or
really even ever used to refer to slave
owners this happened at Harvard and Yale
just a few years ago at Harvard and Yale
the earliest American colleges they
inherited from Oxford and Cambridge the
term master to refer to the head of the
residential colleges so you have some
Dean's and you have a master of the
college and that's sort of like the
social head of the college the term
master comes from Oxford from Cambridge
we use the term master all the time when
we use the word mr. to
for a new stranger on the street hello
mr. Smith mr. is just a form of master
so we use that term it has nothing to do
with slavery it predates slavery by
centuries in the Oxford and Cambridge
tradition and yet student activists and
political activists at Harvard and Yale
said no the word master it sounds kind
of slavey
I know it has no relation to slavery
whatsoever but it just kind of sounds
it's in the feels like all my fields
make it sound really slavey so we have
to get rid of it and they did they
dropped those terms so now they use the
phrase head of college I'm sure they're
gonna find some way to be offended by a
head of college too and then they're
gonna change it again that's the
ignorance part it's people don't really
get what the word owner means that the
word owner doesn't come from slavery but
the other side of it I think is even
more important which is creeping
socialism it's not about the racism it's
about ownership itself
we're uncomfortable in this egalitarian
society where socialism is becoming much
more popular where the majority of young
Americans now are identifying as
socialist we're uncomfortable with
private ownership itself just as a rule
whenever someone accuses you of racism
it's they're probably not talking about
racism racism has become a tool of the
left to silence people and to push
forward their other ideas racism is
rarely if ever actually about racism so
the question of whether owner is racist
is not about racism
it's about ownerships you have got
people like Alexandria Cassio Cortez and
Bernie Sanders and I guess now the
entire Democrat field just about telling
us that private property is bad it's
wrong need to take away private property
in the extreme case we need socialism we
need socialist programs that is the line
so people feel shame for owning private
property why do you have the right to
own something if that guy on the street
doesn't have the right to own it why do
I have the right to own my car when the
bum drink and booze out of a plastic
bottle on the street doesn't own a car
according to the radical egalitarians
there's something unfair about that
that's an example of social injustice
actually though private
property is great private property is
one of the best things ever and shared
property is not that great we are told
in this culture that private property is
bad and in primitive that in an advanced
society we will give up some of our
private ownership of property and then
we'll all just hold things in common
like the mythical people and the
beautiful paradise that we envision
before the social contract that's we are
being told Tim Cook the CEO of Apple
gave a speech at Tulane University where
he said that in the beginning we all
just kept our property to ourselves and
we all just did things for ourselves but
then when we became civilized we
realized we needed to do everything
together and we needed to surrender our
ownership and we needed to just kumbaya
all together the actual history of
civilization is exactly the opposite
primitive tribes are not the most
selfish they don't have the most private
ownership they they're not the most
capitalistic primitive tribes are the
most socialistic they don't really have
concepts of private property when you
look at primitive tribes in Papua New
Guinea or in the Amazon jungle or in
historical examples they don't really
hold private property they hold all the
goods in common and their economies
don't really take off they don't really
produce very much they don't enter into
a state of advanced civilization it
doesn't grow society societies only
begin to advance when they develop
concepts of private property and when
they develop concepts of government and
law to protect that private property and
the reason for that is only when you
have private property do you have any
incentive to work to produce to till the
land this this is true not just in the
ancient civilizations or in the remote
tribes in Papua New Guinea this is true
in American history when the Mayflower
sailed to America in 1620 and those
early pilgrims got off the ship they
held their property in common and you
know what happened they starved they had
a very terrible first winter they had a
very terrible second winter it was only
after they started to Institute
capitalist reforms that they had
abundance this is well attested to in
the diaries of the governor of
plymouth governor Bradford they decided
instead of holding everything in common
and trying to get everyone else to work
for everyone else they would divvy up
the property governor Bradford wrote
that at that time when they were sharing
all of the property the young men felt
that they had no reason to go out there
and work for some other man's wife to be
able to eat they would just sit at home
and everyone else would do the work and
then they would hopefully enjoy some
some of the fruits of the other person's
labor this is what happens in communist
governments it perhaps it starts out
with good intentions usually it doesn't
but let's say that it did start out with
good intentions the trouble is in the
system itself in the system itself if
I'm just gonna get the fruits of
someone's labor if we're all gonna get
the average why would I ever work above
the average in fact why would ever work
at the average amount of productivity
I'm gonna try to work below the average
amount of productivity so that I'm
really profiting from somebody else's
labor because that's much easier and
there's no difference in what I get to
eat or the goods that I get to enjoy so
governor Bradford then divided up all
the property and guess what happened
Plymouth Plantation flourished and New
England flourished and America learned a
very important lesson in those early
years the other side of private property
is that is it is implied by natural
rights and natural law so all the time
now when socialists are ranting about
social justice and how we need to give
up private property ownership and we
need to I mean what socialism is
literally when the government takes
control of the means of production and
distribution in an economy which when
they take away private property and
private ownership what we are told is
that really it's a higher justice it's
human rights
that call for us to take other people's
property for ourselves actually the
opposite is true private property is a
concept of the natural law and of
natural rights our country is grounded
in the idea of natural rights to life
liberty and the pursuit of happiness
which John Locke described as the
pursuit of property why is private
property implied by natural rights and
natural law it's because it is a
consequence of my liberty so I have life
I have this life that I was given and I
can act freely in it
so I act freely and I work and I occupy
certain places and as a result of this I
have to be entitled to some profit for
my work my liberty I have to be entitled
to some of the fruits of my Liberty and
this implies private property what is
the argument for taking away someone
else's private property that Alexandria
okay Oh Cassio Cortes really wants it
mmm that's not a great argument that the
world will end if we don't take away a
lot of people's private property in 12
years
not really backed by science like AOC
wants it to be
they have no argument for this when the
left can't make an argument against this
they they have to revert to what they
always do which is they cry racism they
say you're a bigot you're racist you're
selfish gimme gimme gimme that's what's
really going on here in this debate and
by the way we saw this in action
yesterday this this concept this
frequent tool of the left to just accuse
their opponents of racism when they
don't have an argument we saw it in an
interview that Jared Kushner did on HBO
over the question of whether birtherism
the idea that Barack Obama wasn't born
in the u.s. whether birtherism is racist
and he totally bungled the answer
alexandria Ocasio Cortez she calls she
has cold President Trump a racist have
you ever seen him say or do anything
that you would describe as racist or
bigoted so for the answer is no
absolutely not you can't not be a racist
for 69 years then run for president be a
racist and what I'll say is that when a
lot of the Democrats call the president
a racist I think they're doing a
disservice to people who suffer because
of real racism in this country was
birtherism racist look I wasn't really
involved in that I know you would
mm-hmm was it racist like I said I
wasn't involved in that I know you would
mm-hmm was it racist um look I know who
the president is and I have not seen
anything in him that is racist so again
I was not involved in that did you wish
he didn't do that like I said I was not
involved in that that was a long time
ago the other issue that often gets
brought up in this conversation is that
he campaigned on banning
Muslims would you describe that as
religiously bigoted look I think that
the President did his campaign the way
he did his campaign did and I think you
wish he didn't she wish she didn't make
that speech I think he's here today and
I think he's doing a lot of great things
for the country and that's what I'm
proud of uh totally bungled it I like
Jared Kushner but this was not a good
answer in any case the answer to the
question is birtherism racist is
obviously no it's not racist the answer
on the Muslim band by the way is that
Barack Obama limited travel from from
many of the countries that Donald Trump
did and mitt and his ban the travel
restrictions were not exclusively
against Muslim majority countries and
also it was a ban against countries that
were failed states that we couldn't
ensure the the legitimacy of the people
who were coming over here so that that's
simply answered and the question of
birtherism is simply answered to
birtherism is not racist where does
birtherism come from the idea that
Barack Obama wasn't born here it comes
from Barack Obama himself Barack Obama's
literary agent wrote in in one of the
early promotions for Barack Obama as a
published writer that he was born in
Kenya this is what he wrote rock obama
the first american african-american
president of the Harvard Law Review was
born in Kenya and raised in Indonesia
and Hawaii the son of an American
anthropologist and a Kenyan finance
minister he attended Columbia University
and worked as a financial journalist and
editor for a business international
corporation and then it goes on it says
it very clearly he was born in Kenya now
the guy says this was a mistake we have
every reason to believe it was a mistake
but it was a mistake that came from
Barack Obama in his literary agent and
it was distributed widely why else did
people think Barack Obama wasn't born
here they thought that because he
doesn't speak like an American
he doesn't speak in the sort of ideas
that are traditionally American ideas he
put very publicly rejected American
exceptionalism he was asked if he
believed in American exceptionalism and
he said yeah sure I believe in it just
the way that the Greeks believe in Greek
exceptionalism which belies a
fundamental understanding of American
exceptionalism if every country is
exceptional then no country is X
and the idea of American exceptionalism
is that America by virtue of it her
unique development and foundation and
role in the world is unique it's almost
tautological little it's just a very
basic observation that America unlike
every other country on earth is
exceptional not to say it's the greatest
thing in the whole history of the world
though it is the greatest nation in the
history of the world it simply says it
is the exception to nations not the rule
when you look at the unique founding of
America the unique development obviously
that is true I think he was probably the
first major presidential candidate ever
to reject American exceptionalism he
also described muslim prayers in the
evening as one of the prettiest sounds
on earth that's a little strange that's
not totally in keeping with traditional
american views of religion and beauty
it's a it's a foreign idea why else he
grew up abroad he did grow up largely in
indonesia why else he piled around with
Marxists like Frank Marshall Davis and
he credited those Marxists as his
Mentors why else he piled around with
domestic terrorists like Bill Ayers he
launched his political campaign in the
living room of Bill Ayers why else
because his ideas were on American also
it doesn't even make sense that
birtherism would be racist the idea that
Barack Obama wasn't born in this country
because he was black
is that what birtherism is because there
were a lot of black people in America
black people have been in America for
centuries that part wouldn't even
because somebody is black they wouldn't
be born in America but black people are
12% of the American population
no it was because he seemed foreign and
because when he was young his publisher
said that he or his literary agent
rather said that he was not born in
America and because he spoke like
someone who is not American birtherism
had other problems than this first of
all there's not much evidence for it
other than what his literary agent said
decades ago and the other major problem
with birtherism which is why I never
took the controversy seriously at all is
that even if Barack Obama had been born
in
some other place he still would be a
natural-born citizen because he was a
citizen upon his birth natural just
means from birth so because his mother
was a US citizen he was naturally born a
US citizen so it didn't even really
matter Kushner should have just said
this ya birtherism wasn't racist might
have been stupid it might have been
foolish it was by the way based on
Barack Obama's own literary agent but
sure it turned out it wasn't true okay
it's not racist
none of that shows that it's racist if
everything is racist
nothing is racist we should not give the
left an inch we should not accept their
premises a good example of how Kushner
should have responded to this came by
way of steven crowder yesterday because
you know there's this vox journalist
just trying to get crowder
banned from YouTube for making jokes and
YouTube is taking this apparently
seriously they're actively investigating
crowder they want to get rid of his
channel I think his channel has like 4
million subscribers or something and
this jerk from Vox this total fake
victim punk named Carlos masa made a
video yesterday explaining why we need
to censor crowder here he is people have
talked about this way before I did and
have experienced it way worse than I
have YouTube is dominated by all right
monsters who use the platform to target
their critics and make their lives
miserable isn't happening for a long
time it's been happening since way
before me the response from people
who've experienced this is yeah I agree
to hell with YouTube I can't believe
they're branding themselves as
frightened allies and I heard you have
Raymond Brown coming up later on this
show I hope you asked him what it's like
to make basically corporate propaganda
for a company that doesn't care about
bird people I want to stop it right
there because did you hear the word he
said at the end he said that YouTube
doesn't care about people who are making
fun of queer people and he's using the
word queer people as his own identity I
mean the guy's Twitter handle is gay
wonk so he's saying we are queer people
and it's wrong to make fun of us well
how did steven crowder make fun of queer
people he called them queer he used the
very word that they use to describe
themselves he used the very word that
this guy used to describe himself but I
guess when he says that it's okay and
when Steven Crowder says it it's not
okay and why is that because he doesn't
like steven crowder and he wants Steven
cried her to shut up because steven
crowder is a conservative so he will
baselessly smear steven crowder as some
sort of neo-nazi he's using the term
alt-right alt-right used to have a
meaning all right referred to a a
political movement a very small
political movement that is racially
essential racially essentialist and so
it prioritizes race above all other
political questions and concerns it is
largely materialist it's a largely
atheistic movement conservatives
mainstream conservatives reject the
premises of that movement entirely this
guy totally baselessly smearing crowder
is that now then he goes on with his
suggestions for youtube the response
from critics people who love steven
crowder had been that i'm a fascist and
i'm an embassy NBC plants trying to t
that takedown a competitor which is like
so dumb i don't know what to say to it
but it's meant to distract from the
reality which is that steven crowder is
not the problem
alex jones isn't the problem these
individual actors are not the problem
they are symptoms and the products of
youtube's design which is meant to
reward the most inflammatory bigoted and
engaging performers steven crowder is
youtube's ideal creator he makes cheap
long content that tons of people walk
and subscribe to he sells shirts on the
platform that say socialism is for [ __ ]
like youtube continues to allow he is
what an ideal YouTube creator looks like
and YouTube's branding about caring
about queer people is meant to distract
advertisers from the fact that they have
no handle on their platform and that
people who run ads on YouTube are gonna
end up having their ads appear on videos
with hate speech and bigoted harassment
of free people and marginalized meetings
so what he just said about steven
crowder shirts is also technically not
true because this shirt says that
socialism is for figs and instead of in
a it's a little picture of a fig and
coincidentally che guevara who's
pictured on the shirt was killed in a
town called Higuera which means the fig
tree so anyway i'm quibbling over a
minor point here but the long story
short is this guy's a whiny little liar
and he's a fake victim because he refers
to marginalized communities there's no
more margin
last community on social media than
conservatives conservatives are
regularly demonetized shut down a sensor
D platformed kicked off their end and by
the way if we're trying to compare the
marginalization of conservatives on
social media to queer people to use
Carlos Mazdas term conservatives
regularly being D platforms regularly
being kicked off social media this very
show gets censored not infrequently I
have been kicked off of Twitter for
various periods of time
that's conservatives in terms of gay
people in LGBT LMNOP the the term Pride
Month has been trending for three
consecutive days on Twitter not only are
queer people to use this term not
marginalized on social media they are
celebrated every day fine by me but
there's no comparison here now we'll get
to Crowder's apology and in a second but
first I've got a saying about a Facebook
and YouTube and we've got a whole lot
more to get to we've got to get to my
the funniest story that I've read in the
news in many months about how a weird
kinky sexual meetup turned into assault
and robbery and we will have to get to
susan b anthony and uncovering whether
the left or right can accurately claim
her but go to daily wire.com if you want
at ten bucks a month $100 for an annual
membership you get me at the end plate
and show you get the Ben Shapiro show
you get the mount wall show you get to
ask questions in the mailbag coming up
on Thursday you get to ask questions
backstage you get everything but you get
the leftist ears tumblr and this is very
very important you're gonna mmm that's
really good I'm really proud of how
delicious the leftist ears tumblr Tay I
just take a lot of pride in it I think
we should all be proud of how delicious
leftist ears Tumblr's or if you want to
be proud of salty leftist ears go to
daily wire comm we'll be right back
so Crowder issued an apology he's under
a lot of pressure they're threatening to
take away his entire business from him
they're threatening to take away his
entire show for him because some whiny
little leftist punk doesn't like him and
so Crowder understandably he just
published a video and said I'm sorry
let's hear what he had to say it's been
brought to my attention that many of the
comments videos an overall tenor and
tone of this program have been
considered hurtful and offensive to many
and while not in violation of policy
guidelines certainly started the line of
human decency I along with everyone here
at ladder with Crowder I'm not above
recognizing my mistakes and attempting
to rectify them so I'd like to take this
opportunity to formally apologize to all
parties involved firstly my heartfelt
apologies to practicing socialists
offended by the Che Guevara socialism is
for FIGS t-shirt I know that we should
fight bad ideas with good ideas and
respectfully debate the merits virtues
and shortcomings of socialism as opposed
to merely mocking it with a hysterical
t-shirt available at ladder with credit
shop comm also my apologies to the
Nabisco corporation and their Fig Newton
subsidiary I would also like to
apologize to Drake the rapper for
referring to him as a quote butter-soft
[ __ ] and claiming that his only
redeeming quality as a performer was
when he was shot into permanent
paralysis on Degrassi I'd also like to
apologize to Justice Ruth Bader Ginsburg
from plying that she's long been
deceased and even though I don't have
verifiable proof to the contrary I do
realize my observations were conducted
in poor taste and ill-timed
I also apologized for pant Ellis's
remarks implying that she looks like a
cartoon snail librarian this is exactly
how conservatives should respond when
whiney leftist Punk's try to get in our
face about our various opinions we
should reject their premises and then we
should laugh at them because it's I
think it's actually because the
mainstream media is so insane and I mean
not just the news not just the
newspapers but Hollywood TV movies all
this it's because the mainstream media
are so insane that we sometimes
forget that most people are normal so
even while we're talking about 56
genders on Facebook and you know
shrieking crazy people on college
campuses Donald Trump got elected
president that's one fact another of
fact Fox News beats out CNN every night
there's another fact last-man-standing
a totally normal sitcom about totally
normal people doing totally normal
things is an extremely popular TV show
you could go on and on and on most
people are pretty normal it's just the
people who control our popular culture
are the ones who are totally insane
don't let them scare you stand up to
them stare them in the eye and laugh
right in their face which brings us to
my favorite story I've read in months
speaking of the intersection of
interesting sexuality and comedy there's
a story that came out today it's so good
I have to read it to you in its entirety
it's so tip of eyes what we have been
talking about with our total cultural
obsession about sex and casual sex and
the sexual revolution of the hook-up
culture this story from the New York
Post quote a Greenwich Village man was
allegedly robbed by a date he met on
Grindr reinder is a gay dating app but
told cops he couldn't scream for help
because he had a quote jockstrap and
ball gag in his mouth
police sources said Monday police
responded to a call of a home invasion
robbery around 3:00 a.m. Saturday at the
26 year old victims apartment on
Greenwich Street police said the man
told police he had met his date in a
section of the app called closure ears
if you don't want to hear this black men
love fisting the sources said he said
the two men had consensual intercourse
that included latex bottles rubber
gloves a leash and a sex swing but they
got into an argument over the small size
of the perps package leading him to
choke the victim and demand cash the
sources said the victim told cops he
thought it was part of the fantasy until
his date allegedly dragged him into a
closet and took $3,000 sorry the victim
told cops he tried to scream when he
realized he was being robbed but
couldn't the sources said
the robber fled and the victim was
treated on the scene cops took latex
gloves a sex toy and the sex swing is
evidence the source said the suspect was
described as being in his 30s with a
goatee and wearing white t-shirt black
sweatpants and a black hoodie police
said police canvassed the area but
didn't find the perp I don't mean to
laugh at this guy
getting robbed it's it's too bad for
that guy if you feel sorry for him and I
I also don't mean to pick on gay guys
because this obviously this story
involved two gay guys this could have
involved straight people or people who
have any any sort of sexual preferences
the rule is true for everybody when your
sexual fantasies and desires and acts
are indistinguishable from assault
battery and robbery you have lost the
plot you've lost the narrative something
needs to change because the key to the
story is that the guy the victim is kind
of making fun of his partner's natural
endowments and then the guy starts
yelling at him and getting physical and
drags him into a closet and puts a ball
gag on his mouth and at that moment the
victim thought it was part of the
fantasy so he thought this was actually
a moment of great pleasure when in fact
it was a moment of great pain because he
was about to lose three grand and have
to wait in his closet for a few hours
something is wrong our sexual culture if
you not if this happens look this people
get robbed people domestic abuse happens
violence habit that's not the new thing
the thing that's new is that the guy
thought it was pleasure the guy thought
it was part of the fantasy the guy
already had the ball gag in his mouth
the police had to confiscate a sex swing
and a bunch of other weird stuff and
latex gloves it's too much guys
too much dial it back a little bit all
right look I mean what two people do in
the privacy of their own home is of no
interest to me unless it's a really
funny story in the New York Post but
something's gone wrong here and actually
this is borne out by statistics both
tinder which is the straight version of
grinder and grinder are more dangerous
than ever both of them accord
to a UK report crimes that have begun on
tinder and Grindr have increased nearly
three-fold from 2013 to 2014 and
Sevenfold from 2013 to 2015 and that was
four years ago who knows how high that
is now that is a set you don't need to
you don't need to be some Orthodox
Christian or some Bible Belt religious
zealot person you don't need to go to
church regularly you don't need to take
any particular view on sexual morality
or any of it to read that story and say
maybe something's gone a little wrong in
our culture we're now told we shouldn't
have any shame straight gay asexual
bisexual and whatever you're not
supposed to have any shame for your
desires every sexual desire is supposed
to be really great no they're not
obviously not when you're when you're
being mugged and you think being mugged
as part of your sexual desire something
has gone wrong maybe you should rethink
what you are engaging in and what you
are doing and I'm sure that I'll be
labeled some kind of phob for pointing
out that sex between two loving adults
should not resemble assault battery and
Robert II but there it is there it is
that's all I can say
speaking of morality and religion bad
news out of the Vatican today Pope
Francis has just rewritten the Lord's
Prayer so the Our Father The Lord's
Prayer is a very simple prayer it's it's
a prayer that Christ Himself gives the
Apostles and I'm sure you've heard it
but it goes our Father who art in heaven
hallowed be thy name thy kingdom come
thy will be done on earth as it is in
heaven give us this day our daily bread
and forgive us our trespasses as we
forgive those who trespass against us
and lead us not into temptation but
deliver us from evil
you see lead us not into temptation is
from God you are asking God not to lead
you into temptation that is the point
but what Pope Francis is saying is that
God could never lead you into temptation
only the devil leads you into temptation
except this is contradicted in Scripture
right around the time in the gospel
where Christ gives the apostles the
Lord's Prayer he is
led by the spirit into the wilderness to
be tempted by the devil it is the spirit
that is doing the leading the Spirit of
God and the devil is doing the tempting
how is that possible it is not for me to
know I don't know that I don't
understand all of the mind of God I
couldn't possibly understand the mind of
God that is not possible for finite
creatures like human beings but I
likewise don't want to go in there and
edit the words of Christ himself because
I think I have a better idea than he did
that this is a huge mistake and it's an
example of hubris and religion you see
this ultra religion really bad move from
Pope Francis and I will not be editing
the words of Christ in the Lord's Prayer
and I suspect a lot of Christians around
the world won't be doing it either
people have some difficulty with
scripture we all have difficulty with
Scripture I think Cardinal Newman one of
the greatest theologians ever said that
10,000 problems does not make one doubt
there have been Cardinals who have said
that they don't understand all of
Scripture of course we couldn't
understand all of theology if we could
it wouldn't be true theology we can
never understand the mind of God it
shouldn't lead us to rewrite the Bible
and to rewrite the Lord's Prayer now
this brings us to the 19th amendment we
have to get to it before we close today
susan b anthony 100 years ago today the
senate-passed
Woman Suffrage gave women the right to
vote this was passed largely thanks to
susan b anthony susan b anthony the OG
women's rights activist it's also worth
noting that susan b anthony was
staunchly pro-life this has become a
matter of political debate in recent
years was susan b anthony pro-life or
was she not the susan b anthony list
which is a pro-life organization takes
its name obviously from susan b anthony
but a lot of pro-abortion groups say
that she wasn't pro-life there's no
evidence that she personally disagreed
with abortion this is not true so what
why do they make this case in a journal
that susan b anthony owned called the
revolution abortion
was referred to as child murder and
antenatal infanticide so before birth
infanticide one article in this journal
read quote guilty yes no matter what the
motive love of ease or a desire to save
from suffering the unborn innocent
the woman is awfully guilty who commits
the deed it will burden her conscience
in life it will burden her soul in death
but oath rice guilty is he who for
selfish gratification drove her to the
desperation which impelled her to the
crime and this was signed a and now we
don't know what a is a has been
interpreted by some people to mean
Anthony we've been told by other
scholars it doesn't mean Anthony that
when susan b anthony signed her name she
signed it s b a and actually a could
have referred to a different writer in
the publication okay maybe the journal
was edited by fellow feminists Elizabeth
Cady Stanton whose husband helped to
found the Republican Party and founded
by Parker Pillsbury also ardently
pro-life and the journal included both
sides of issues so it could be the case
they say that even though susan b
anthony was pro-abortion the journal
presented the anti-abortion side as well
this falls apart when we see the
advertising policy in the journal in the
journal had a very explicit advertising
policy which read quack medicine vendors
however rich proud and pretentious fetus
IDEs and infanticides should be clasped
together and regarded with shuddering
horror by the whole human race hard to
hard to argue with that that advertising
policy would not have gone into effect
without the approval of the owner of the
journal susan b anthony regardless even
of the authorship of any of those lines
we still know that susan b anthony was
pro-life why because she defended quote
the unborn little ones she used that
phrase the unborn little ones now she's
not referring to the unborn random clump
of cells she's not referring to the
unborn
the unborn last July or the unborn
embryo or the mbone unborn fetus or she
refers to the unborn little ones unborn
means they're to be born the
suffragettes Frances Willard who was a
friend of susan b anthony recounted one
time that a man said that of all women
susan b anthony should have been a wife
and a mother she wasn't a wife and a
mother and susan b anthony reply was
quote i thank you sir but sweeter even
than to have had the joy of caring for
children of my own has it been to me to
help bring about a better state of
things for mothers generally so that
their unborn little ones could not be
willed away from them pretty clear she
also referred to in fantasize and
abortions as some of the greatest evils
associated with alcoholism so a lot of
the suffragettes were involved in the
temperance movement too very very awful
trying to get men to stop drinking booze
and trying to push for prohibition and
one of the reasons for this is they said
men get drunk and then they go have sex
with women and then they knock him up
but they're totally unresponsible rather
and then the women are go and compelled
to have abortions and she said that
these abortions and these and fanta
sides are some of the greatest evils
associated with booze but it's only an
evil if abortion and infanticide are
evil which obviously she believed was
the case and the the last bit of
evidence we have here i mean there's a
lot more but just the last bit that we
have time for is that susan b anthony
his own sister had an abortion and susan
b anthony wrote in her private diary
about this she said she will rue it the
day she forces nature she will rue the
day why will she rue the day that she
has an abortion we're told today that
abortion is empowering
we're told that it's something you
should be proud of we're told that it's
something you should shout from the
rooftops it's not something that should
be safe legal and rare it should be on
demand up until the moment of birth it's
so good it's so great to be able to have
an abortion that you should shout it
with joy and with pride susan b anthony
didn't think that why because she
thought it was evil and she thought it
caused regret and she wouldn't
quack medicine people who would kill
babies and in fetuses so-called
to advertise in her journal and she
defended the unborn little ones and and
she published people who referred very
explicitly to the evils of abortion it's
pretty clear that the susan b anthony
list has it right here the pro-life
movement has it right and you'll see
trending all over the internet the 19th
amendment susan b anthony women's rights
well the leading women's rights
activists opposed abortion at the top of
their class women's rights activists
opposed abortion today in the abortion
debate we hear women's rights and
abortion referred to synonymously it's
like they're the same thing women's
women's reproductive rights women's
healthcare women's health the the women
that we credit with starting the modern
feminist movement that all of these
these modern feminists hold up as the
the forebears of their movement the most
important among them opposed abortion
that's an inconvenient fact they
probably won't be admitting it anytime
soon but we should remind them whenever
that whenever the 19th amendment is
trending whenever there are celebrations
to celebrate women's suffrage bring that
up because those early suffragettes
those early feminists defended women not
just when they turned 18 or 21 and they
could vote but they defended them all
the way before they were even born when
they were unborn little ones all right
that's our show more to get to but you
know that's the way it goes
come back tomorrow and we'll have a lot
more in the meantime I'm Michael nose
this is the Michael Nolt show I'll see
you then
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Rebecca dobkins and directed by Mike
joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Dani D'Amico Audio is mixed by
Dylan case hair and makeup is by Joshua
Alvaro and our production assistant is
Nick Sheehan the Michael Noel's show is
a daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 19 today on the Matt Walsh show
people in this country don't seem to
understand Christianity in case you
haven't noticed and that's why today
there's outrage because a pastor prayed
for the president and outraged because a
Catholic bishop came out against gay
pride parades nobody should be shocked
by either thing and nobody would be
shocked if they had a basic
understanding of Christianity we'll talk
about that also
Texas has banned red light cameras this
is cause for celebration even for a
parade maybe and I'll explain why Plus
I'll answer your emails today on the
Matt Walsh show